tonight President Trump will travel to
Capitol Hill for his second official
State of the Union address speech
fulfills the constitutional requirement
that the president from time to time
give to the Congress information of the
State of the Union over two centuries
that simple mandate evolved from a
written report into an annual primetime
address part laundry list of policy
proposals part theatrical performance
and always an odd display of applause
and silence mr. speaker madam speaker
mr. speaker mr. speaker speaker for
decades those words have marked the
beginning of presidential speeches with
a recurring theme I am pleased to report
the state of our union is stronger than
a year ago George Washington delivered
the first annual address in 1790
referring to the gentlemen of the Senate
and House because that's all there were
gentlemen Jefferson thought the show too
kingly so he kicked off a century of
submitting the address in writing the
president's attitude typewriter that
ended in 1913 when Woodrow Wilson
revived the tradition of the in person
speech and more than two decades later
Franklin Delano Roosevelt helped
solidify the name
in 1965 mired in the Vietnam War Lyndon
Johnson moved the speech to primetime to
try to persuade a larger audience we are
strong and we have proven our resolve
and during the 1982 address Ronald
Reagan added the latest innovation by
highlighting his presidential guests we
saw the heroism of one of our young
government employees Lenny Skutnik
occasionally the evening produces an
enduring line an axis of evil the era of
big government is over but more often
it's a marathon of proposals and
promises and big aspirations and tonight
I am announcing I ask you to support
this initiative in two weeks I will send
you a budget but this time it's
different
after a 35 day partial government
shutdown delayed his speech President
Trump has promised to strike a healing
tone I really think it's going to be a
speech it's going to cover a lot of
territory but part of its going to be
unity but he hasn't sounded very
unifying lately you have people dying
all over the country because of people
like Nancy Pelosi she's doing a terrible
disservice to our country it's more than
likely that the country's divisions
could again be on display this night
used to be a time to capitalize on the
presidential megaphone but for a
president in a state of constant
communication his future tweets are
likely to supersede his formal remarks
still tens of millions of Americans are
likely to tune in and for a president
who likes a big audience and who likes
to break the rules anything could happen